if efforts from both sides take place we
can count on relieving a certain tension
it will not be fast or easy as we stated
more than once
we positively judged a proposal of the
president joe biden to hold a summit
putin had indicated he wanted to meet
with me uh
well over a month ago i've spoken with
him
a number of times we don't expect
everything to be solved at the end of
this
meeting but we think that it is in our
interest to to have the meeting which is
why we proposed it to the president were
there any preconditions
no well they'll be meeting
in geneva in a few weeks the president
on the way out to marie one
also said that it was too late for the
nordstrom
2 sanctions to take place that he said
the pipeline
was almost completed by the time he took
office and
it would be counterproductive to say
that european relations would be
affected
i'm against it but it's too late
essentially is what he said
but um there's an election in germany
coming up
and the leading group that possibly
could win
taking over for chancellor angler merkel
is a green party that is
opposed to that pipeline so what then
we're back with our panel
uh ben this is interesting play as
russia continues to poke the u.s
an interesting play i mean i think it's
a disappointing play in a lot of
different ways
i can only imagine what then-candidate
joe biden would be saying
if then president trump had been engaged
in a lot of these different activities
that are essentially
playing very softly with russia i'm
going to be curious about a number of
things coming out of this meeting but
one of the big things i'll be paying
attention to is if the subject of alexei
navalny
is even brought up to me that's
something that has to be brought up in
any conversation with vladimir putin
regardless
of anything else that's on the table
because of the importance of that issue
we'll it'll be interesting to see if joe
biden does that charlie
you know it's just amazing uh to you
know the the bottom line here is
uh joe biden might be against the
pipeline in europe but he
he green lighted it and of course here
in the united states the first thing he
did
one of his first actions as president
was to kill a pipeline in the united
states who's he working for i don't know
the um well take a listen to the
criticism of this summit harold
russia is tries to poke poke the united
states in the eye every day they can
um it's so he's he's a thug he's not a
friend
i you know i'd it'd be nice if something
could happen out of it we may have
forgotten
over the last couple of years but this
is how diplomacy works we don't work
together
uh we don't meet with people only when
we agree it's actually
important to meet with leaders when we
have a range of disagreements
as we do with russian leaders so we
don't regard the meeting with the
russian president as a reward we regard
it as a vital part of defending
america's interests
for all the years of democrats
criticizing president trump for
being what they said was too close to
russia or somehow being a russian
agent it does seem like the policies of
the biden administration are a little
softer than what the trump
administration was to russia
i would differ there i think this
president no president in my lifetime
has brought more experience with the
exception of possibly president george
h.w bush
around foreign policy in this president
he's been blunt
he's been serious he's been forthright
and he's been transparent about what he
wants to get done here
look i think ben's right he has to raise
a navalny issue and i'm sure the
president
will president biden also knows that
president putin
is facing joblessness joblessness and
corruption it's abound in the country so
he will be blunt with him
president biden also knows that our real
adversary in the 21st century
where the economic fight is to be
engaged with china so i have great
confidence that the president
will find the right tone the right
temperament and more importantly the
right
substantive uh blunting of of russia in
this meeting in geneva
and there's questions about china as
well whether he has the same
talking points there's uh on that front
as well okay panel stand by when we come
back tomorrow's headlines
tonight hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else